ah I'm doing it I'm doing it Pass oh
yeah she left me hanging what is up guys
my name is Kristen Farina I'm a
professional dancer you might recognize
me from the TV show world of dance and
today I'm going to teach some drunk
non-dancers some dance moves I'm about
as drunk as Miley Cyrus in 2010 I'm
gonna beat everybody because I'm gonna
bring fun I'm gonna bring flavor so
let's get started
all right class we're actually gonna
start with something a little more viral
and trendy I think you guys know this
one we'll start easy anyone know how to
shoot okay yes if you guys want to just
like follow along with me take your
right hand and your right foot put it
back like this so you want your arm and
your leg doing the same thing at the
same time so you're gonna bring your
legs forward
and your arms back yeah yeah jump when
it's back and then you land when it's
forward ready five six seven eight jump
jump jump jump nice you don't just have
to do your arm here you can bring it
down as well so you jump is it it isn't
you can do it either to meet five six
seven eight
I have no idea where I look like it was
alright maybe not
alright so we're gonna do it one had
time to see if you pass or fail starting
with new rhyme oh let's go about throw
up in the back alright alright let's set
yourself up for success okay okay you
know what I'm doing it I'm doing it I
like the confidence I would just say go
home and work on it necessarily say pass
but like it's okay you're welcome
[Music]
and pass you kids that have a little bit
more fun but that was song they did
pretty good we got that one let's move
on to the whoa moving on this is the
probably the most popular dance trend
right now yeah the whoa right hand in
there yes okay so we'll start basic so
you have your hand you got really
believe this what you're gonna do is
you're gonna bring this right hand over
your body and as you bring it down you
wanna stop it well you want to imagine
[Applause]
if I'm like dancing hey hey that was
good one at a time Brian first rehearse
okay okay I give you props at fun you're
dancing dancing dancing dancing one two
three four five six seven eight one pass
she left me hanging oh no we're gonna
throw five hitting on the one one two
three four five six seven eight one yeah
they all pass it they killed that one so
let's get a little bit harder another
trendy move we're gonna hit the folks
some of you might know
hit the folks it sounds as folks never
it sounds better look it's something
I've seen before it's this one six this
would just be like hitting the folk so I
think you're advancing you can do the
steps into it so stepping on our right
foot we go across six seven up eight hit
one sick one two three four five six
seven eight one but that was more than
it
that was like it so when the club we're
dancing dance dance one on five one two
three four five six seven eight one okay
okay
nice commitment pass we go one two three
four five six seven eight one nice only
thing you have to step with your right
foot first yeah alright last move
honestly I've been keeping it pretty
easy for them I think they're really
gonna struggle with this one especially
since they're drunk it's called this
means alright you guys are you ready for
the last one so I was keeping it easy
for you we're going a little bit harder
it's called the sneeze you ever watch a
dance video and you see a group of
dancers after like the dance is done and
they all like partying free back
together yeah jump around me and hype me
up really quick it's like this like
hopping like you can move around so
we're gonna take it step by step I'm
gonna see if you guys can get it okay
probably right foot in the air you're
gonna put your foot down
and you're just tapping it down and
you're hopping on booth whiny somebody
wait a minute I don't I don't know
actually I feel like I know I I don't
have time over I took a half past your
bottom like it's kind of going out weird
I don't even know how you do that
honestly work on that one next up long
legs five okay maybe just go home and
take it slow just like huh I don't know
what you're talking about that's exactly
what I did if you think you've passing
[Music]
okay a little bit more happen to know
what I'm not it so that was pretty good
they got the first thing moves last one
was a little iffy but I knew it was
gonna be hard for them they're drunk so
it's fine today they did a great job all
right how do you guys feel do you think
you can take these moves and bring them
to the club
absolutely professionals now the thing
is that we practiced a drum which means
you practice like the play I'm gonna do
these drunk so there we go
with that five six seven eight whoa
[Music]
[Music]